he's the head coach of the Houston
Cougars he's Tom Herman you know we look
did the researcher we like the
background story here now he's done a
great job there at Houston he's 18 and
one in his 19 games there but he has
held various positions in the sports
broadcasting industry and the Tom joins
us now let's start there tom first of
all good morning thanks for joining us
give us an idea of the best job you had
in sports and the worst job in in
broadcasting you had uh I appreciate you
having me dan I would say that the
funnest job I had was at Cal Lutheran
when I was a student I was allowed to be
the PA announcer so I was I was actually
the PA announcer for men's and women's
basketball for women's volleyball and
for baseball and so I had a blast doing
that it paid me like 25 bucks a game and
it was uh it was a the funnest time I
had the worst job I I was like a
marketing guy for like extra am-11 50
extra there in Los Angeles and although
it sounds fun you know we'd reach the
right around like that like the Hummer
and throw t-shirts at people on the
beach and all that stuff and that it
sounds like a blast but it was it was
pretty boring oh wait you're part of the
street team for extra sports where
you're going to the beach to hand out
t-shirts huh I think that I was at one
point in my life yeah absolutely did you
also cut highlights for foxes NFL show I
did yeah I was uh every Sunday during
the season it was cool you know Division
three football playing Division three
allowed me a lot more freedom during the
season so on Sundays I would drive down
to wherever I can't remember where the
studios are but down there also off the
101 and go in and and I got to shake
hands with with Howie and JB and those
guys and sit there and get paid to watch
NFL games and cut highlight wait how old
were you you'd like 20 21
probably 21 maybe yeah something like
that it was a union job too so how about
this DP so every now and again you'd
show up and if they only had one game
for you to watch you watched your your
four hours worth of that that game but
they paid you for eight I thought that
was the coolest thing man i started uh
really enjoying the the whole Union
thing there for a while do you ever get
yelled at for your highlights uh not
that I can remember that it was a long
time ago but I'm probably I get yelled
at for everything if you didn't go into
coaching like were you thinking of doing
it having some kind of job in sports
broadcasting yeah i really i thought
that that's what I wanted to do and I
thought that would keep me close to the
game and and and no offense to sports
broadcasters but it just didn't tell all
of my interactions with with it you know
I had so a couple radio show or yeah
radio shows and stuff like that that it
just it just didn't it wasn't like being
in the locker room and I said you know
what I'm gonna try this coaching thing
while I'm young and and know that I'm
not going to make any money and you know
from 29 30 and I don't like it or things
aren't working out you know maybe i'll
switch has at that point but i just the
sports broadcasting thing this wasn't
quite close enough not not quite as
relational as I I wanted it to be he
said Tom Herman the Houston head coach
brought to you by Continental Tire
coaches corner what was your dream job
when you got into this business as far
as coaching
oh man I don't I I set a goal I don't I
don't I don't know that I ever had a
dream job shoot at the time I my wife
from a small town outside of Fresno
called fireball California I probably
said five fresno state might have been
my dream job back then just as you know
so she wouldn't have to be to live the
Nomad life that that us coaches lead but
I set a goal that I wanted to be either
a one double a coordinator or division
1a position coach by the time I was 30
and if I didn't achieve that gold and I
was going to get out at coaching and
probably moved back to California and go
try to support my family some some way
else so I think that was just kind of
you know I set really short term goals
and didn't really worry about dream jobs
at this at that time why do we assume
you will take another job soon with your
success in Houston ah that's a good
question i don't i don't know i don't
know i think because the public likes to
assume things the public I mean there's
a reason you have a job right then I
mean it's because of people like to form
opinions about things that they can't
control and and they think that they
have some kind of knowledge about
another human beings mindset or a frame
of mind and so I get it it's human
nature it's if things if humans weren't
wired that way then you wouldn't have a
job and we wouldn't have fans and you
know the world would be a much different
place but I I don't know i don't i never
waste my time or try not to at least
formulate in opinions about things that
I can't control well you do have some
control in it but also some guys are
wired differently there's always the guy
who feels like he can fix something and
it's three years here and then three
years there and then three years there
even in my business where you say oh I
got to keep moving where in your
business Kirk Ferentz decides that Iowa
is going to be his home and that's where
he's going to have his coaching career
and he's fine with that we're
other coaches feel like they have to
keep moving what's your personality like
are you a fixer keep moving forward like
a shark or can you be stationary oh I
think I you be stationary that the
moving part especially with you know I'm
41 that we we have a three-year-old at
the house I got a 12 year old daughter
that's you know starting or in the
middle of middle school nine-year-old
son i think you know moving as many
times i think at one point we move like
six times in ten years oh man so I think
I think stationary always sounds better
from a from a family point but again you
also you want to win championships tan
in this business and we all got into
this business hopefully for two reasons
one was to change in effect young men's
lives in a positive way and then to to
win and compete and I think you have to
make sure if you're going to stay
somewhere though that you're you're
given the resources and an opportunity
to to win championships can you win a
championship in national title at
Houston oh I i think this year certainly
yeah i think we've got as good a team as
anybody in the country for three hours
on a saturday is it tough to schedule
teams you know and now that Houston's
you know on the map here that it used to
be they had no problem probably but are
you finding that may be the bigger
schools are saying I don't know if we
want to home at home here with you uh
you know honestly I I don't know because
I'm you know they don't they don't bring
the scheduling stuff to me until it's
you know a thumbs-up thumbs-down seal of
approval you good with this you're not
good with this so I don't know how
difficult it is to get to that point
what what happens if I'm late to one of
your meetings oh that's a bad deal um
this is uh you're probably going to get
publicly admonished in front of your
peers and told what a bad teammate you
are for for doing that and
um severely punished in terms of some
kind of really not fun and grueling type
of calisthenics at a very early hour and
morning way yeah what's the best excuse
you ever had when one of your players
was late for me oh man best excuse
there's there's been a bunch of them um
you know my the one that always gets me
as well my my phone was on silent and my
ringer was low it's like man when I go
to bed at night and I know we're all
it's like I said like 17 alarms on my
phone I had my wife said to her I mean
that's every night and I'm just I'm so
paranoid and I don't know how these kids
can't be the same way but there's a good
teaching them I know I know their kids
man we all did this you were probably
like that when you were 18 I did I
remember uh I actually overslept the
first team meeting we had for a brand
new head coach oh the we switched
coaches at Cal Lutheran from Joe Harper
to Scott Squires my junior year and yeah
I overslept uh I did the whole p.m.
instead of am on the alarm deal how
about you against ohio state how it
would help would would you like that
kind of scenario here in the U and urban
I know because I know how good they yeah
because you might have to hear coach
well I I know and and will be prepared
and ready uh you know we played some
pretty good football teams in our short
time here too and have have come out the
other side pretty good but uh yeah i
mean i did i'd always be fun you know to
play a mentor i used to love when i had
an opportunity when i was at iowa state
to play against texas and mack brown and
those guys that it kind of brought me up
in this business so I
anytime you have an opportunity to play
against a mentor i think is as good a
final question it's a serious one could
Urban Meyer take Jim Harbaugh if he had
to oh man you're gonna you're gonna
dissin quote who's going to be all over
the Internet if yes absolutely he could
and that's where all all of my money
would be and I think he would be a Vegas
favorite good luck against Navy thank
you Tom we appreciate it and good luck
whatever other future holds there for
you all right then enjoy your show
thanks for having me go Cougs all right
that's uh Tom her head coach houston
cougars go Cougs brought to you by
Continental Tire coach's corner for any
surface any season there's Continental
Tire that delivers superior performance
on paralleled safety give your vehicle
and upgrade with Continentals maximum
performance tires for more info on that
tire you can go to continental tire calm
from speedway to driveway continental
put you in the driver's seat the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience